sí Bueno finalmente Los Leones del Atlas
no han conseguido vencer a la selección
de Francia en este partido de
semifinales un partido que Francia
dominó pues prácticamente en todo
momento de hecho el primer gol de Teo
Hernández llegó en los primeros cinco
minutos el segundo en la segunda parte
Aquí estaba todo el mundo muy nervioso
muy tenso pero finalmente no pudo ser y
hasta aquí llega a Marruecos en este
mundial en un mundial en el que Cabe
destacar que han hecho historia y es que
esta ha sido la primera vez que la
selecciona de Marruecos llega en la
historia a la semifinales y también Esa
es la primera vez en la historia Pues
que una selección de un país que es
árabe amajij y áfricano consigue llegar
a esta fase del mundial aquí en
Marruecos la verdad es que todo el mundo
se ha volcado desde el primer momento
con la selección el fútbol ha conseguido
de nuevo unir a todo el país y todo el
mundo la verdad es que estaba muy
ilusionado al final pues la victoria no
ha podido ser Y bueno pues Los
Seguidores de los leones de la tasa
abandonan este mundial se despiden de él
sin haber podido llegar a la final pero
se van muy atentos con mucha felicidad y
con mucho orgullo de saber que tienen el
mejor equipo de todos esos tiempos de
casi lo han demostrado en todos los
duelos hasta día de hoy también se va se
van muy contentos de aquí pues por saber
que han conseguido hacer historia